Este congreso de la República quiero enviarle
un saludo afectuoso
y de agradecimiento a todos los equipos
del partido Alianza verde en el departamento de Caldas,
un partido que este fin de semana
precisamente
logrando ese trabajo y esa cohesión en equipo,
garantiza que hoy tengamos a David Len Ramírez,
diputado del partido.
Opinamos en norcacia y hacemos pegatón
después de reunión con la gente en la vereda Isaza
y gobernador de Caldas,
con quien haremos equipo
frente a las decisiones que toma el gobierno Nacional
para respaldar los diferentes
proyectos de desarrollo
que necesita el departamento de Caldas.
Gracias también
a nuestros concejales
elegidos en los diferentes municipios
por su trabajo intenso y persistencia para lograrlo.
Hacerle un llamado al gobierno Nacional
para que acompañe precisamente
la tarea y la labor de los
concejales, de los gobernadores y de los alcaldes
de todo el país,
para que de esa forma podamos sacar adelante
esos proyectos productivos
que sigan potenciando nuestro país
en materia económica